you
everyone this is Jason with her go
Asians here with you today for the
eighth session in our quick training
sessions and today we're going to spend
a little bit of time talking about
adaptive path and kind of some ways to
put that to use we'll show you a little
bit about or talk about what it does and
then physically show you how how to put
it into use so we will go ahead and get
started to start with as with our other
sessions I'll go ahead and mention we
will be utilizing the wind Mad Max
desktop software for those of you that
have already been logging on you know
this is just another solution that her
co offers which allows you to do your
programming and verification at your
desktop you can then take that program
that you create out commissioning and
run it there if any of you are
interested in a trial version of that
either to practice what we're going over
today or any of the other videos we've
done or to see if that's something that
may benefit your shop at the bottom of
the screen you're looking at you can see
that the marketing crew put together a
real nice link to make the getting of
this software a little easier but if you
just go to her co.com forward slash
software you can download a trial
version of the desktop software and we
can help you with getting that all set
up so you can either follow along with
presentations or see if this is
something that may be a benefit in your
shop so with that let's get into
gap to pass the first thing that we'll
do for those of you that may not be
familiar with adaptive path it's just
kind of talk a little bit about what it
is or what it what it does what are the
benefits so first off adaptive path is
part of the altie pockets option on your
machine the majority of the machines out
there do have this option on them so if
you have that option you already have
adaptive path assuming your software is
up to a version 9 software if you do
have all T pockets and you don't have
adaptive path I will put up the contact
information at the end of this
presentation let us know and we can look
at your version and see what it would
take to get you to a version that will
have adaptive path once we go through
this you'll see that it is a very
beneficial tool it's going to be
something that is going to save you you
time and money in your machine so if you
don't have the option and it looks like
you should let us know and we will get
that all ironed out for you but adaptive
path is essentially a pocketing strategy
now later on in this session we're going
to show you a couple ways to manipulate
it so we can use it for some other
purposes other than pocketing but it is
primarily a pocketing strategy which is
why it's tied in with that ulti pockets
option the the adaptive path is
basically a constant tool engagement
tool path there's a lot of these styles
of tool paths out there a lot of
different machine tool manufacturers and
cam systems have versions of this and
they have different names the one that I
tend to use most more than other than
adept path that is would be high
efficiency machining that kind of
describes it a little bit better than
some of the others I think but you may
have heard people refer to things as you
know dynamic mill true milled requital
milling there's many names out there
most of which are escaping me right now
but adaptive path is our version of that
tool path and basically all of these
all paths have a few similarities
between them and that is going to be
you're going to be taking a large depth
of cut with a little bit smaller width
of cut essentially whatever your flute
length is on your end mill if you need
to go that deep that's what you're going
to take if you've seen any been watching
machining videos or anything like that
online you've probably seen this type of
cut and so what a lot of people are
going to to get a little bit more
efficient tool path and we'll kind of
show you how how the control makes this
makes us a bailable or make this an
option this is a roughing strategy it's
meant to remove material very quickly
so you will typically use a finish pass
with this as well if you if you don't
leave a finish pass if you do have
finished sidewalls you will see a little
bit of marks on those sides because this
is intended to be a roughing strategy it
is meant to remove a lot of material
very quickly so that being said let's
show you a little bit how it how it does
this I get my screen to advance here
there we go so I have on the screen a
couple tool paths you know we on the top
we have the standard tool path which is
basically you're going to go in you're
going to plunge on Center you're going
to step over and then you're just going
to take a cut in this case a circular
cut as the finished geometry would be a
circle you're going to machine around
and then when you get to your starting
point you're basically just going to
step over and take another circular path
or follow your geometry you're just
going to keep doing that basically
stepping over and then cutting the same
shape well what we're trying to
eliminate here is that step over move
every time you get to that start point
and it comes time to transition over to
the next cut your tool is engaging a lot
material more material than in your your
standard routine there so typically you
have to base all your feeds and speeds
your step over depth of cut
that's all typically based off of that
little transition move because that's
where you're going to be engaging the
most material so what a adaptive path
does is the circle shows it very well
here you're going to start in the middle
and the control is just going to spiral
outward hit whatever width of cut you
gave it whatever step over you gave it
it's going to spiral outward at a
constant spiral constant step over when
this is cutting if you were to listen to
the Machine you're going to notice that
the entire cut sounds the same you're
not getting into those areas where here
where you hear the machine engaging more
material and the sound changes once you
start this spiral it will never engage
more material than what you told it to
take which is how adaptive path can
allow you to take the larger depth of
cuts and use the fight the faster feed
rates as well you will notice that when
it gets to the outside edge of this
circular shape there will be some time
where it will have to take less of a
width of cut but the important thing
here is it will never never take a
larger width of cut than what you told
it to the theory with these style of
cuts is if you were to picture yourself
taking a cut just on the side of this
part you maybe you're taking a finished
passer or whatever you're going to give
it whatever depth of cut you need so if
you're going one inch deep and you have
one inch flute length on your end mil
I'll just go ahead and take that depth
of cut if you were to take a straight
line cut along the edge of your part you
can dial in your feeds and speeds with
the cut
you know dial all that in and then you
can use those same parameters for your
pocketing because the control will
guarantee that you will never take more
than that with the cut to do that you
specified so the spiral works really
well for this circular
obviously there's times where you're
going to need something other than the
circular shape if we take a look at this
here this is a good example of a part
that is obviously not circular and you
can see here the control is still going
to come in it's going to start and it's
going to kind of pick a location where
you can get the most out of this spiral
and it's going to try to spiral outward
until it can no longer hold that step
over that you gave it and any time it
comes to a point where it would have to
engage more material it's going to react
in one of two ways we have two options
here and we'll show you both of those
here in a second but one is a zig zag
method and the other we call one-way if
you have it set to zig zag when it comes
time to wear it would have to engage
more material you know it's not just
going to plunge that tool right through
this area here it was is now going to
just start cutting back and forth it's
going to zigzag back and forth holding
that with the cut that you specified or
that step over the important thing is
again it's not going to engage more
material than what you told it to so you
can use those higher depths of cuts and
higher feed rates if you choose the one
way option rather than zigzagging back
and forth it will then it will take a
cut and then do a little transition move
to go back to take another cut so
essentially you have the option of
climber conventional typically even set
this to be a climb cut it'll basically
take a climb cut do a little transition
move back and take another climb cut
always maintaining that step over that
you specified the one way method is a
little bit more common you see that used
a little bit more again I believe just
because of the always climb cutting
typically when you see these types of
tool path you'll notice a little arc
move like that there and then just a
straight-line move to start your other
your other cut or your next cut that
transition move between the where it
stopped
starts next cut it will lift up a little
bit in Z as well so it's not dragging
that tool right across your park so
we've got two methods which we're going
to work with here in just a second but
that is basically how adapt Pass works
it is going to constantly check your
tool engagement to make sure that you
never take more of a width of cut to
what you specify
so now that we've kind of talked a
little bit about it let's go ahead and
and put it to you to show you how you
would do that what I'm going to bring up
the the wind max desktop
and we have a part here that's already
been programmed
make sure I'm on the right one we'll go
ahead and draw so this here is just a
standard pocket nothing more than a milf
frame where I put in some different
corner radiuses the justice so some
different geometry so we can kind of see
how the adaptive path reacts once we
turn that on and we have an island here
in the center again just to kind of
force some different motion out of the
software if we take a look at the data
block nothing out of the ordinary yet we
do did utilize the corners tab which
some of you may not be quite as familiar
with but basically I just made one of
these arcs a larger arc than the other
three so that gives us the geometry we
were just looking at on the screen and
you can see we did make it a pocket
boundary now in order to utilize the
adaptive path we're going to go down
here to our pocket type this is where a
lot of you are probably used to seeing
the inward and outward cut type we have
two more options here now with with
adaptive path we have the adaptive fat
zigzag and the one way that we mentioned
on the previous slide so we'll go ahead
and just choose one of these I'm going
to start with one way and the first
thing you may notice if you've been
programming with conversational for a
while it just added another tab that
you're not used to be seeing this is a a
rest tab this will allow us to go in and
clean out any corners that may have been
left by too large of a tool so in this
case here I have a 200-thousand corner
radius on three of these four corners
and you'll notice that I am using a
three quarter inch end mill so my my
roughing tool is just a little bit too
large to clean up those corners rather
than switching to a larger tool we're
going to deal with that in the rest tab
here in just a minute you'll notice my
targeted step over which was 40%
my standard pocketing routine I'm going
to go ahead and back this down a little
bit we'll use about a 20% step over for
adaptive path again we're going to be
taking a much larger depth to cut and a
little bit smaller with the cut I'm
going to make sure that my PEC depth
remains at zero I want to take this all
at one shot we're only going three cores
an inch deep with this pocket we have a
three-quarter inch in mil as long as we
have 3/4 inch of flute length we should
be good to go
taking us all at one shot so we'll jump
over to the rest machining here again
this is going to allow us to go in and
kind of clean out these corners that are
too small for that larger cutter I'll go
ahead and draw this now that we turned
on the adaptive path we'll be able to
see that and some of you may notice if
you just start using a depth pass for
the first time it will take it a second
or two longer to process your tool path
if it's a complex pocket there's just
more motion that the control has to to
work through to do this style of a cut
so that is something that is common with
the depth that you will notice but if we
take a look here Izu min on my corners
you'll see that we have these little
moves here to pick out the corners this
is that smaller end mill we happen to
choose a 3 a 10 mil to go in and pick
out these corners we can give it a peck
debt since obviously it's a smaller
cutter you may not want to be going cold
depth with that then give it its own
speeds and feed so you can set this up
as its own operation this is a standard
routine this is kind of like just
programming a contour here there's not
going to be any of that constant or any
of that engagement checks being done
here it's just going to take the tool
that you gave it and go pick out those
corners now one exception that you will
see when you go to program this is you
notice I've got these lines these tool
this tool paths joining these corners
they had made a change to the software
to try to keep the tool down
and are going to be putting this back
right now it's actually machining this
wall that will be switched back it will
actually lift the tool up go to the next
Peck depth and then go over to your your
next corner so what I'm seeing here will
be slightly different than what you will
see when you go to program this on your
own
typically we would just see a rapid move
here and then a plunge move down to the
next active but that's the the rest
machining allows you to rough with a
tool that's you know going to be most
efficient you know typically the larger
the tool the better so you can rough out
with a little bit larger tool go in and
pick out your corners and it will do
this before it does your finish path so
you don't have to worry about engaging a
bunch of material when you come in to
finish this wall so I use the tool 3/8
in mil for the rest machining we will
now go into the finish tab you'll see
we're also using that same tool for a
finishing pass as I mentioned before
this is a roughing strategy so you will
want to make sure to go in and program a
finish pass and I'm not sure how many of
you have been using the allowance tab
here we did a session on the the program
parameters and you remember that if you
go into your milling and set your stock
allowance mode two data blocks you can
now control all your your stock
allowances right here in this allowance
tab you will notice that I left my Z
depth at zero if you do leave your Z
depth at zero it will just take the pass
around the outside it won't finish the
whole floor sometimes that's okay other
times you may want a little bit nicer
finish on your floor so you can just go
in here and give it a a allow an
allowance for your z as well I go to
redraw this now let's go into my XY view
we've got a couple of different things
going on you'll see we have the adaptive
path you were taking the cut and doing
the transition back over and taking
another cut
but you also now see that we have what
looks like a standard pocketing routine
there as well when you take a finish
pass that will always be the standard
pocketing routine it's not going to be
doing the adaptive pass style of cut
which is typically fine you know you've
gotten all the material out of there and
now you're just finishing that floor so
you will notice that your finishing pass
will always be the standard routine and
you do have all the same control in your
finishing pass as you do on your
standard pocketing or the roughing where
you can set the step over and speeds and
feeds so that is the basics of how you
work with adaptive path and notice it's
not a whole lot to get it to work other
than what you're already used to and
setting your your pocket type when you
set your milling type with the addition
of the rest machining notice we do have
the arrows that can take a little bit of
getting used to for those of you that
have had to use those in the past you
may need to hit these arrows to kind of
be able to see that all the tabs that
you need to work with but other than
that that's that's kind of how adaptive
path works now there's a couple things
we can do in here to make it you know so
we can use it in other ways let's go in
and take a look at another option here
you
I'm sorry for my my poking around here I
thought I had created one other program
you
all right yeah we're going to let this
one I'm going to pull up another program
you're sorry about that so the next
thing I want to talk about is is open
pocket there are times when you're
programming or maybe you want to leave
an open pocket so you can come in and
essentially plunge outside of your stock
now this is a very efficient method for
removing material so there's a lot of
times this will be your go-to strategy
for removing a lot of material but let's
say we had a part
that looks something like this here just
a simple frame I did set up some stock
geometry so this does represent the
stock that put in the machine
but let's say we want a machine all this
way we want this to be an island
now we could very easily just go in and
program a frame on the outside of this
and tell that's a boundary and that this
frame and center is an island and it
would go ahead and machine all that away
and do a pretty efficient job at it but
since we are removing all the material
we have one advantage here that we may
not typically have in most pockets and
that is we could easily go in and plunge
outside of our material so that we don't
have to take the time to Hilux and I'm
going to be a little easier on the tool
and we'll be able to get that plunge
move done quicker so I'm going to walk
through how to do that
let me deal and I'm just checking my
stock geometry so I can check my stock
size here so we have a six by six by one
inch piece of material and by the
reference position here I can see that
part zero is right in the middle
it gives me what I need to do to start
programming so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to insert a block before this
frame and I'm just going to go into
lines and arcs and I'm going to just
program a U shape or a c-shape that's
just slightly larger than the stock that
I have and I'm going to leave one side
open so we'll just start let's say I'm
going to start at an X of minus three
point two five and a Y of minus three
point two five I think that frame was
going to half-inch deep so we'll take a
look at that so go to my next segment
and at minus three point two five and a
y of positive three point two five
you
continue over two positive three point
two five and x and y and then my next
segment will be my final segment I'm
going to end it three point two five and
my Y will be minus three point two five
so if you were able to follow along you
know it's kind of hard without prints
and dimensions if I look at my graphics
screen
I mean minimize this just for a second
essentially what I've done is I've come
in and I've programmed something just
like that they're just in an open
boundary on the outside of my part now
we'll go put this to use
I tell what tool I want to use I'm gonna
tell it I want to do a pocket boundary
and now I'm just gonna go ahead and set
adaptive path just like we did before
and I'll give it my my step over the
nice thing about adaptive path for those
of you that are used to open pockets in
the past you'd go in and there's a few
steps and things that you had to do to
make sure that everything worked the way
you wanted but adapt a path that's not
necessary we just leave the open
boundary as soon as we set it to adapt
to path it's kind of look at it slightly
different and when we go to draw this we
should see we now have I made yet
another mistake on this part here I
forgot to turn this frame into an island
we'll go fix that but you'll notice that
we're now plunging on the outside of our
stock and it's using our step over and
that constant engagement it's always
checking that step over to make sure
that we never engage more material and
what we told it so let me go ahead and
fix the program I'm just going to go
into my second data block the mill frame
I'm gonna set that to a pocket island
now when I draw this
hmm
kind of see what we've got going on here
we're using the adapt path style it's
kind of keep stepping over it whatever
your with the cut is until it can no
longer do so and then these are going to
use your one-way or zigzag to remove the
rest of the material now there's two
other things I need to kind of mention
here one of them is there is a new
parameter that you are not going to be
familiar with if you haven't used a
depth to path before if we go into our
program parameters and the milling to
tab we now have this adaptive path link
length tolerance multiplier if we look
at the description down here adaptive
path link moves above this tolerance
will retract it rapid then plunge so
what this is wanting to know is if it
has to make a transition do you want it
to pick up the tool or leave it down
typically I will set this to the largest
value that it'll take which is a hundred
and try to force it to keep that tool
down as much as possible if there are
any islands or anything in the way the
control is still going to be checking
against those so you don't have to worry
about it wiping out an island or
anything like that so I typically just
leave my tool down as much as possible
remembering that it will if you're doing
the D move or the little transition
moves it will pick up slightly so it's
not dragging on the floor so I typically
will put this in at about 100 and when I
go to draw this you may notice that some
of these plunge moves down here in the
lower right hand corner may go away in
this case here it's a pretty large parts
when we not get all of those gone yeah
so now you can see here we have one
plunge versus however many were there
before so basically that parameters just
want is just telling it you know to keep
the tool down for that given distance
before has to retrack so that's how you
would use open pockets it's very simple
just leave your pocket open until you
want to do an adaptive path now there's
one other feature and this was the
feature I was looking for just a minute
ago when I started fumbling around with
with programs expand boundary this is
primarily used if you're importing data
in from a DXF file or a solid model or
something like that there where you're
just going to select geometry if you
have geometry that is to the print and
you want to make sure you step over a
little further to clean it up to make
sure you don't leave any material
standing you can go in and tell it you
want to expand the boundary so when we
programmed this we went ahead and we
compensated ourselves you know we went
to minus three and a quarter and X and
so just going to minus three inches so
we we compensated for that ourselves if
this was a closed boundary and we wanted
the control to do that for us
automatically we can just go in there
tell yes I want to expand the boundary
and gave it and have given at that
quarter inch distance there so at this
time this is just for closed geometry
and so if you were to maybe import a
frame or or something similar to that in
from a solid model from your graphics
screen you could then just go in and
tell it you wanted to expand that
distance to make sure you cleaned
everything up
so that there is essentially what we
have to offer there with a adaptive pass
I'm going to go ahead and take a look at
the chat section here to see what
questions have come up if you have any
questions you can feel free to unmute
yourself or go ahead and ask them in the
chat in our chat window give me one just
second or one second here and I'll take
a look
okay Luke has a good question here what
is the average cycle time advantage over
standard outward or inward milling
routines this is somewhat of a hard one
to answer because it's very application
specific and it depends on the depth and
everything that you're that you're
programming but your standard pockets
you are going to see considerable
cutting time reduction and I actually
let me take a look for one folder here I
believe I have a picture of one one
example
you
yeah a lot of the images I have here
have been taken from a presentation that
Mike coppa done a while ago I happen to
find this in there as well
this is actually that first shape we
were kind of talking about adaptive path
but you can see with the standard when
max tool path through six minutes and
three seconds let's adapt the path
you're two minutes and 23 seconds this
is primarily coming or due to the fact
that you can you're probably going to
take this entire pocket at one shot
you're not going to take the small pecks
at it the some of the other advantages
come in and that you can physically run
your tools faster and feed them harder
it seems that the tool manufacturers
prefer this style of cutting and once
you start doing this that's it's kind of
amazing how much faster you can kind of
feed things through the part so I don't
know what the you know it's not always
going to be a little different you see
on this party 2% faster that's that's
probably I don't know if that would be
kind of standard what you'd expect to
see it seems like it is quite a bit
faster there I would say you're
typically going to be about half or so
but it is very application specific and
Dean asked us do you have to be on
version 9 or newer and yet she do this
was a an option that was brought in on
version 9 so it won't be available on
the version 7 or 8 software
you
mm-hmm and Doug is asking about a face
face specific application here what if
you have notches on the inside of a part
Doug had shared a picture with me awhile
ago of a specific part and and basically
what it was was a circle with some let's
say frames cut in the outside of it what
I would do on that type of application
is I would probably program one of those
frames as an open contour and just make
it extend out just a little bit past
your circular pocket let it machine all
of that away and then just do a pattern
to rotate it around I think is how I
would do that
look at another good comment here on one
of the the application engineers he he
works one of our distributors he was
saying his engineer was able to push a
to push a tool at 350 inches a minute on
a VM 10 using a coated in mill in 41 40
it was using adaptive pass and in cut
dry so this is kind of see this a lot
you will notice when you're watching
these videos a lot of times you will see
guys cutting dry and a lot of that is
just due to the fact that when you're
you're cutting your feed rates are
higher you're typically throwing these
chips well out of the hole that you're
in and you know a lot of the tools now
are are kind of designed to be cut dry
yeah that was a that was a good example
of what you can expect with with
adaptive path
alright are there any other questions on
adaptive pass if not I'll go ahead and
stop the recording and we can kind of
have a question-and-answer session on
any topic or maybe suggestions or
anything like that but we'll give you a
give you a minute or so here to see if
there's any other adaptive pass
questions
you